Parfois ce sont des moments de joie
et parfois ils sont déchirants,
tragiques.
Mais si durant de tels moments, nous faisons le bon choix,
nous accomplissons un miracle
pour nous et pour autrui.
Mon fils unique Tariq, étudiant à l'université,
bienveillant, généreux, bon écrivain et photographe,
aspirait à travailler pour le National Geographic.
Il était fiancé à une belle jeune fille
et travaillait comme livreur de pizza les vendredis et samedis.
Il fut attiré à une fausse adresse
par un gang de jeunes.
Et lors d'un rite d'initiation,
un jeune de 14 ans lui a tiré dessus et l'a tué.
La mort subite et insensée
d'un être humain innocent et non armé ;
le chagrin accablant d'une famille ;
la confusion totale en essayant d'accepter une nouvelle et hideuse réalité.
Il va sans dire que ma vie s'est brutalement arrêtée.
Une des choses les plus difficiles que j'aie jamais eues à faire
fut d'appeler sa mère qui vivait dans une autre ville.
Comment annoncer à une mère qu'elle ne reverra plus jamais son fils,
ne l'entendra plus rire
ou ne l'embrassera plus ?
Je suis musulman soufi pratiquant.
Je médite deux heures par jour.
Et parfois,
au milieu d'un traumatisme ou d'une tragédie,
une étincelle de clarté apparaît.
Donc l'illumination que j'ai reçue pendant ma méditation,
c'est qu'il y avait des victimes des deux côtés de l'arme.
Il est facile de considérer mon fils comme la victime d'un enfant de 14 ans,
mais plus difficile de voir qu'il était victime de la société américaine.
Et cela soulève la question : qu'est-ce que la société américaine ?
Eh bien, c'est vous et moi
car je ne crois pas que la société soit juste le fruit du hasard.
Je pense que nous sommes tous responsables de la société que nous avons créée.
Et des enfants qui en tuent d'autres n'est pas le signe d'une société civile.
Alors, neuf mois après la mort de Tariq,
j'ai créé la fondation Tariq Khamisa
et notre objectif principal à la fondation Tariq Khamisa
est d'empêcher les enfants de s’entre-tuer
en brisant le cycle de la violence chez les jeunes.
Nous avons trois objectifs principaux.
Le plus important, c'est de sauver la vie des enfants.
C'est primordial. Nous en perdons tellement tous les jours.
Notre second objectif,
c'est de promouvoir les bons choix pour qu'ils ne quittent pas le bon chemin
en choisissant une vie de crimes, de drogue, d'alcool et d'armes.
Et notre troisième objectif, c'est de leur enseigner les principes
de la non-violence, de l'empathie, de la compassion
et du pardon.
J'ai commencé avec une logique très simple :
la violence est un comportement acquis.
Aucun enfant ne naît violent.
Si vous acceptez ce truisme,
la non-violence peut aussi s'apprendre,
mais il faut l'enseigner
car les enfants ne l'apprendront pas
machinalement.
J'ai ensuite contacté mon frère, présent ici,
tous les deux ayant perdu un fils.
Mon fils est mort.
Il a perdu son petit-fils dans une prison pour adultes.
Alors, je lui ai demandé de me rejoindre.
Et comme vous voyez, 22 ans plus tard, nous sommes toujours ensemble
car moi je ne peux pas ressusciter Tariq
et on ne peut pas libérer Tony de prison,
mais la seule chose que nous pouvons faire
c'est de nous assurer qu’aucun autre enfant de notre communauté
ne meure ou ne finisse en prison.
Avec l'aide de Dieu,
la fondation Tariq Khamisa a connu un grand succès.
Nous avons un modèle d'école sûre
qui offre quatre programmes différents.
Le premier est une conférence avec Ples et moi.
Nous sommes présentés,
le petit-fils de celui-ci a tué le fils de celui-là,
mais ils sont ici ensemble.
Nous avons un programme en classe,
un programme extrascolaire et nous avons créé un club pour la paix.
Et je suis ravi de vous dire
qu'en plus d'enseigner ces principes de non-violence,
nous sommes en mesure de réduire les renvois et exclusions de 70%,
ce qui est énorme.
(Applaudissements)
C'est énorme.
Cinq ans après la mort de Tariq,
et pour que j'achève mon chemin vers le pardon,
j'ai rendu visite à celui qui a tué mon fils.
Il avait 19 ans.
Et je me souviens de cette rencontre parce que nous étions --
il a 37 ans et est toujours en prison --
lors de cette rencontre, nous nous sommes fixés intensément.
Je l'ai regardé, il m'a regardé,
j'ai cherché dans ses yeux un meurtrier, mais je ne l'ai pas trouvé.
Je suis allé au-delà de ce regard
et j'ai touché son humanité,
sa lumière n’était pas différente de la mienne
ni de celle de n'importe qui d'autre.
Je ne m'y attendais pas. Il avait des remords.
Il était bien éduqué.
Je peux dire que mon pardon l'a changé.
Merci d'accueillir mon frère, Ples.
(Applaudissements)
Ples Felix : Tony est l'unique fils de mon unique fille.
Quand Tony est né,
ma fille avait 15 ans.
Être mère est la tâche la plus difficile sur Terre.
Il n'y a pas de tâche plus dure au monde que d’élever un être humain
et s'assurer qu'il soit en sécurité,
à même de réussir sa vie.
Tony a connu beaucoup de violence durant son enfance.
Il a vu un de ses cousins préférés
être tué sous une pluie de balles -
il appartenait à un gang de Los Angeles.
Il a été traumatisé de bien des façons.
Tony est venu vivre avec moi.
Je voulais m'assurer qu'il ait tout ce dont un enfant avait besoin
pour réussir.
Mais ce soir-là,
après des années passées avec moi,
luttant pour tenter de réussir
et de répondre à mes attentes de ce qu'est une personne qui réussit,
ce soir-là, Tony s’est enfui de la maison,
il est allé retrouver ceux qu'il considérait ses amis,
on lui a proposé de la drogue et de l'alcool et il en a pris,
pensant que cela le rendrait insouciant.
Mais cela n'a fait qu'amplifier son anxiété,
créant en lui une pensée...
une pensée de mort.
Ils ont fait un braquage.
On lui a donné un pistolet de 9 mm.
En présence d'un garçon de 18 ans lui donnant des ordres
et deux garçons de 14 ans qu'il croyait être ses amis,
il a tiré et tué Tariq Khamisa,
le fils de cet homme.
Aucun mot, aucun mot
ne peut exprimer
la perte d'un enfant.
Quand j'ai compris que mon petit-fils était responsable
du meurtre de cet être humain,
je me suis rendu en salle de prière, comme mes parents me l'avaient appris,
et j'ai commencé à prier et à méditer.
La chose que nous partageons, M. Khamisa et moi,
et que nous ne savions pas, à part être extraordinaires,
est que nous méditons tous les deux.
(Rires)
Cela m'a beaucoup aidé
car cela m'a offert l'opportunité de chercher conseils et clairvoyance
pour soutenir cet homme et sa famille dans leur perte.
Et mes prières furent exaucées
car cet homme m'a invité chez lui, dans sa maison.
J'ai rencontré sa mère, son père,
sa femme, son frère et sa famille,
et j'ai eu la chance d’être en présence de gens touchés par la grâce de Dieu,
guidés par cet homme, qui dans un esprit de pardon,
m'ont accueilli et m'ont donné l'opportunité
de partager avec lui et avec les enfants
l'importance de comprendre la nécessité d’être avec un adulte responsable,
d'utiliser la colère de façon saine
et d'apprendre à méditer.
Les programmes mis en place à la fondation Tariq Khamisa
donnent aux enfants beaucoup d'outils, de ressources
dont ils pourront se servir durant leur vie.
Nos enfants doivent savoir que des adultes aimants, attentionnés
sont là pour eux et les aident
mais il est aussi important qu'ils apprennent à méditer,
à être en paix,
centrés sur eux-mêmes
et apprennent à interagir avec d'autres enfants
avec empathie, gentillesse
et dans l'amour.
Il nous faut plus d'amour dans nos sociétés
et c'est pourquoi nous sommes ici, pour partager l'amour avec eux,
parce que nos enfants vont nous montrer la voie
car nous dépendrons tous de nos enfants.
Quand nous vieillirons et partirons à la retraite, ils nous remplaceront
et nous rendrons tout l'amour que nous leur aurons appris.
Que dieu vous bénisse. Merci.
(Applaudissements)
AK : Je suis né au Kenya, j'ai fait mes études en Angleterre
et mon frère est baptiste.
Je suis un musulman soufi.
Il est afro-américain,
mais je lui dis toujours que je suis l'Afro-Américain du groupe.
Je suis né en Afrique, toi non.
(Rires)
Je suis naturalisé américain.
Je suis un citoyen de première génération.
Et je considérais qu'en tant que citoyen américain,
je devais prendre ma part de responsabilité
dans le meurtre de mon fils.
Pourquoi ? Parce que c'est un enfant américain qui lui a tiré dessus.
Vous pourriez prendre parti : il a tué mon unique fils,
il devrait être pendu haut et court.
Comment cela améliorera-t-il la société ?
Vous vous demandez sûrement ce qu'il est arrivé à ce jeune homme.
Il est toujours en prison. Ce 22 septembre, il a eu 37 ans,
mais j'ai de bonnes nouvelles.
Depuis 12 ans, nous essayons de le faire sortir.
Finalement, il nous rejoindra dans un an.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis très heureux qu'il nous rejoigne,
car je sais que nous l'avons sauvé,
mais il va sauver des dizaines de milliers d'élèves
quand il partagera son expérience
dans les écoles dans lesquelles nous sommes régulièrement présents.
Quand il dira aux enfants : « À 11 ans, j’étais dans un gang.
À 14 ans, j'ai tué le fils de M. Khamisa.
J'ai passé de nombreuses années en prison.
Croyez-moi, ça n'en vaut pas la peine. »
Croyez-vous que les enfants vont l’écouter ?
Oui, car son intonation
sera celle d’une personne qui a appuyé sur la gâchette.
Et je sais qu'il voudrait remonter le temps.
Bien sûr, ce n'est pas possible.
Je le voudrais tant, avoir à nouveau mon fils.
Mon frère aurait de nouveau son petit-fils.
Donc je pense que cela démontre la force du pardon.
Donc qu'avons-nous à retenir de tout cela ?
Je voudrais finir notre rencontre par une citation,
qui est le fondement de mon quatrième livre,
dont, entre parenthèses,
la préface a été écrite par Tony.
Je vous en cite quelques paroles : la bienveillance crée l’amitié.
On ne se fait pas d'amis en les bombardant
mais en propageant la bienveillance.
Ça devrait être évident.
Donc la bienveillance crée l’amitié,
l'amitié durable crée la confiance,
la confiance crée l'empathie,
l'empathie crée la compassion
et la compassion crée la paix.
C'est ma formule de la paix.
La bienveillance, l’amitié, la confiance, l'empathie, la compassion et la paix.
On me demande comment être bienveillant
avec la personne qui a tué votre enfant.
Je leur dis que ça passe par le pardon.
Ça a marché pour moi.
Ça a marché pour ma famille.
Ça a marché pour Tony,
pour sa famille.
Ça peut marcher pour vous et votre famille,
pour Israël et la Palestine, la Corée du Nord et du Sud,
pour l'Irak, l'Afghanistan, l'Iran et la Syrie.
Ça peut marcher pour les États-Unis.
Laissez-moi vous dire ceci, mes sœurs
et quelques frères -
(Rires)
la paix est possible.
Comment je le sais ?
Car je suis en paix.
Merci beaucoup. Namaste.
(Applaudissements)